here's the  homeless shelter coordinator  in martha's vineyard  and here's what she had to say about  this  so what are the most difficult  challenges right now the difficult  challenges are  we have at some point in time they have  to move from here to somewhere else  right we cannot we don't have the  services  to take care of 50 immigrants um and  we we certainly don't have housing we're  in a housing crisis as we are on this  island and so  we don't we can't house everyone here  that lives here and works here we don't  have housing for 50 more people  eventually we have to pick them up and  move them somewhere else we can't take  care of the mirror we don't have a  housing it's a crisis so so uh 50  illegal immigrants from martha's  vineyard is a crisis a humanitarian  crisis what's what they've been calling  it a humanitarian crisis well what is  thousands of illegal immigrants every  single day being funneled into these  border towns and border states what do  you call that